sonia tout va bien pour vous on va vous
faire une interview ardilouze
[Musique]
sonia quel a été le pire moment de votre
vie
qui tu es loin une petite et rwanda et
le burundi l'insultent quand vous
balance le plus souvent
dans des lettres c'est la grèce voilà
votre histoire d'amour la plus naze
l'avant dernière ah oui c
est j en parle pas non non non non non
ah bon non l avant dernière c'est assez
précis quand même un bain la dernière il
vient la semaine prochaine donc tu veux
ah ouais
le plus mauvais souvenirs d'école que
vous ayez
l'arrivée à cluny en bourgogne un ouais
c'était pas facile il fallait que je
m'adapte à cette nouvelle culture passer
des éléphants aux escargots c'est la
pire chose que vous ayez fait en étant
bourré d'avoir voulu grand mon père
m'avait c'est lui qui m'a bourré ce
jour-là donc non
jamais un ton père kaboré et bien je
trouve ça scandaleux
800 variole
la personne qui a fait le plus de mal
je dirais oui
et bien non on n'a pas les couilles seul
qu il fallait bien
même les charges on
attendra les là vient le nom ils
n'arrêtent pas de râler qui se fait chez
les jeunes
qu'est ce cas là
victoire
longue que je suis lente [ __ ] de
placard la mettais pas bien là non et
pourquoi non non je veux pas de gros
plan attends je suis pas venu pour
techcrunch
je suis venu pour le sidaction attends
tu permets que je termine ma dame ah ben
non c'est joliment dit non c'est
faisable c'est joliment dit 1 c'est
beaucoup plus important ce qui va dire
dombasle et tout de suite après la
personne qui vous a fait le plus de mal
dans votre vie à part richard bohringer
ce soir non c'est mon erreur de casting
là derrière
avec le avec leur le pire endroit où
vous ayez habité pire en noir
non en fait le pire endroit où j'ai vécu
c'est peut-être au burundi pendant la
période du massacre parce que on dort
pas tous les jours et on je passe aussi
bien pour le croit voilà votre pire
émission de télévision
font dix mois celle que je retrouve
souvent c'est celle là pourquoi mais ça
s'est pas mal passé non toujours tous
très bien et d'ailleurs merci avait
mignonne et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux